あっはぁ
また俺はとんでもない天才なことを思いついてしまった史奈さん音楽聴くときどうやっ
て聴いてますかとた異例の一般ピープルはイヤホンを使って音楽を聴いていると思い
ますや頬使えば周りの人の迷惑にもならないし自分だけで音楽
危険素晴らしい知るものだイヤホン2話グラビームプラビングだがイヤホンだけだと
自分の聴いてる音楽自分だけでしか危険他の人に自分の音が共有できなくなるんです
これよくな自分だけの殻に閉じこもってジャンルの量産素晴らしさ感動ね話したに共有
できなくなるんです音楽共有して乱暴なんですよあるかな
桜が来て
いうのがみんなでわかっちゃって初めて音楽なんですよ豆腐大根が言いたいのは音楽
共有した皆じゃね音が大きいと人が迷惑になるから音楽をみんなで共有するには人の
迷惑になるってよくないから雷が私は考えついてしまった人に迷惑をかけず大額を
みんなで共有する方法をこういうものがございますイヤホン端子部分さんケーブルこれ
を使うとこういうことになってますすっ
イヤホンのターン性があるんですけどもその先がまた2ついえ本サス用の端子に変わっ
ている
これなー
これ何を意味するかと言いますとさて場合も喉聞くと iphone の穴を2つに
二股にさせる分散させるケーブルですねこうなってるから朝けどチーズこうなってる
からここにまた山をさせば
余波も2人で聞けるようになるというわけでございますこれすごいと思いますよねぇ版
の短所を分散させるケーブルを今回50個準備しました
あっはっは
ダービッツこれやばい予感ですねすごいよ要するにこういうまた二股のやつがあると
これをさっき刺したここに挿せばこういうことをいまだ公挿せばこういうことするなー
今日俺がやりたいのはいやホーム原画計画
五節句僕の iphone から個つなげてと枝は幹にさせていきます最初だけど値段
は彼氏と大量のイヤホンの端子にいやを指すことによってもじゃあ1年で音楽教諭
んですよイヤホンでさらに片耳た足つった片耳ずつだと100人で音楽が聴けるんです
よ4本でな強いが今日の動画100人で音楽を切るイヤホンキャスト作ってみようと
思いますでこれわかんないんでこんなピザスプリットさせてさ
きれいな音になるかというのもちょっとまだわかんないんでまず実験的な感じです
未来子
ここにイヤホンを入れる穴があると分散させるやつを2つ付けます少なくとも飯山が2
つ入るとでもここで山を入れずにまたここで高分散させると聞けるとこれでも3人で
音楽が聴けるなるためにここに当たっつけるって4人で音楽が聞けるようになるとこれ
はただ繰り返していくだけです
いやイベロすごいよまじでもうじゃないよ
100人
みんなで静かに音楽共有できるんですよ手でちょっとモーガンがつなげていきますお
おーー
またかヤバいのは頭の中でどこがところあれなんか何が何だか分からなくなってきた
はい的で無事 iphone につきました一応これで大量の大人数で音が聞けるはず
なのでこれから細かく端子にちょっとイヤホンをはめていきましょう
いやもう恋
はぁはぁ言ってよけどイヤホン50個準備しましたこの時に
店員さんに惹かれました一番安いイヤホン蝶タイで探したんで俺も何度ショベル飾り
たいんですよイヤホンをつけていきましょう
ana
goo
ちょっ
大丈夫かな背景目で鑑定しました確認できるエア方です
家バレたからだったら終わる話題って親もはやじゃないかな快適で100人で聴ける
リヤ本作ってみたんですけどもうまだ実用性があるのとか分からんこれで本当に100
につけるかが実際に過ぎないと分からないがそのレンズでちょっと前よという字が
きれいにやってみましょう何がどうなってるかわかんないテーマに合うなんちゃうこれ
だってよ
おぞましいでくれてから買ってやってる
上じゃねこれやばいどうしよういまいち何がどこにあるんちゃうかなと思っ
ごめんだ治せなくなりましたまあとりあえずからまでどうか別として大事なのは音楽が
聴けるか動画です果たして100人で本当に音楽と聞けるのかどうかちょっと流れるか
どうか聞いてみましょうじゃあさっそくと聞いてみましょう
聞こえるん
すごい
5聞こえます
なんとか聞こえる
これ本当に全部からを閉じてんだか直樹超えてる
4柘植きゃっ子から全部から音出てるちゃんと
ちょっと音でますこれすごいなって100人で聞けますすごいなぁ
もう二度としないです